what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends yep
[Music]
hey everyone and welcome back to another
episode of unwaxed podcast with your
favorite sisters sophia
and sistine i know i gave you that one
today
you guys i don't know what it is but the
vibes are off
when i say off they're off
just like my nerves and my heart
palpitations today
sophia woke up too sophia actually
diagnosed me in the car
on the way to the studio today because i
was just describing how i've been
feeling
and she said yeah you have major anxiety
i go who me well yeah no no no that's a
sofia thing
i don't have that that's true i know
cysteine's never been
one i've always been the vocal one about
my anxiety
and sistine was saying to me in the car
that
oh thank god thank you
mike coming in for the win bringing us
some salsa brought to you by media zone
uh once again thank you for the alcohol
[Music]
a little asmr did you guys hear
the relief happy the gasp when i saw
that
how much i need this happy tuesday
cheers
so as i was saying before um cysteine
was saying
to me all these little things that she
was feeling and she was like i don't
know what it is
my my whole body feels x y and z and
i'll explain it
i was saying that sophia is
very vocal about how she feels she feels
anxious she feels sad
she reports it to the fam and we talk
about it and we move on
same thing with scarlet but i've always
been the type of person just to
internalize everything for some reason
i think that the second i'm vocalize
my emotions and validate them that
i don't know that i'm a weaker person i
have no idea why i do it
it's kind of weird because i feel that
you are emotional in some ways
you're very expressive very emotional
when it comes to
we just had to deal with a bigger
situation a little bit more of like a
family issue or something that
is a lot more stressing on the body you
shut down
and so sistine woke up with those
repressed emotions
feeling kind of off and i go it's
because you didn't say anything you
didn't
speak out you didn't let yourself feel
something it's almost like
when you have to cry and you have that
ball in your throat and you just are
trying to not let it out
that's how i feel all the time yeah i'm
saying that to sophia and she goes
bro you have anxiety well i was saying
there's little things she did when she
was younger it's not me
i'm superhuman no she doesn't think
affects me because she would do things
when she was younger and i was like you
know
you doing these little things behind
your pillow when you're
younger like chewing on your lip or like
yeah the movie
tell everyone i used to suck on my
pillow yeah i don't say i said stuck on
your lips i didn't say pillow ew
what i did as a child to cope with
anxiety is not
ill okay whatever i take off
okay i think this is a very depressing
intro it's kind of we didn't even write
this intro
no we sort of just started and i'm
thanks for listening to us vent you guys
yeah let's move on to happier topics um
we made an
unwaxed tick tock yeah we joined
we caved yes honestly i think people
have told us
why didn't you do this sooner because
that's how you
promote social pages yeah you know what
we're sort of just like cavemen when it
comes to social media
especially when we're trying to promote
a podcast we should be doing something
like that and we're running this all on
our own
and we don't have the people to tell us
hey
maybe you should make a little bit more
assets on reels or tick tock or
maybe make cooler graphics but c and i
just kind of do the very bare minimum
basics
i don't want to say i feel like we're
not doing bare minimum if you think
about it
it's pretty cool to know that everything
we put out there
is 100 us that's true so it's not done
by some professional video editors or
people making that no one's uploading
for us we're doing it ourselves so
that's
pat on the back for that all right so
yes follow our tick tock what is the
username
it's just unwaxed podcast and we are
going to
flood you guys with really really funny
content that we might have not clipped
it before
so yes definitely follow elusive content
exclusive content to find anywhere else
in other news
sophia and i just got back from another
weekend
in miami little update for you guys on
the apartment hunt
i think we found the home yeah i think
we did and it took a bit
i'm glad we spent this whole few months
a couple months just looking through
everything really getting to know the
area
and we felt this certain place i'm not
going to disclose location because i'm
not having anyone stalk us
is where we see ourselves and i think
that we had to get to that point where
we could just sit and go
okay i can see it's walking to grab this
coffee or going to this gym
because you must visualize when you're
coming to a new place can i see myself
living here and
i never thought i would find that in
miami i kind of just wanted to do
anything other than los angeles but i
actually found it and i think we found
our neighborhood
and it was really exciting the whole
weekend in itself
you know there's no shortage of random
insane things that happened to sofia and
i
oh my god i mean right when this
happened we looked at each other you
guys
and we said this is going to be unwaxed
how can we not share this
of course with with things in miami it
doesn't come without having some
insane experiences so sistine and i
we're rushing we're
really late to this dinner and we are
like we need to get up to the room
get dressed and go correct me if i'm
wrong but when you rush to get ready
you actually end up looking better than
if you sit there and take your time
no it's true so i feel like we we pulled
it together
but that's not the point of the
conversation the point is on our way
to go rush and get ready we get in the
elevator
and all of a sudden we hear
your elevator is having technical
difficulties
it's almost like just when things
couldn't get worse
i it's almost like a higher power just
went haha so
watch this it was me sistine and
this one other older lady and
when i say her face went white my face
went white
and so did sistine she started swearing
and
praying in spanish at the same time i'm
not good with i didn't think i had
claustrophobia
i have claustrophobia getting stuck in
an elevator
genuinely and we were in a high building
this was like
while we're going up it stops let me
give you guys my point of view
i'm dealing with sophia that has
claustrophobia
she's freaking this is her new discovery
the lassophobia and claustrophobia we're
figuring it out
and then this other lady who is praying
right now because she's freaking out
she's on our hands and knees like
basically i
am at my wit's end that you know when
you just crack
and you just start laughing because you
got it just
it just got worse like i didn't think it
could so we're stuck in an elevator
so much fun so much fun so much fun
thankfully all of a sudden the doors
opened some random floor we jump out the
lady
rolls out she just she threw her back
she was sweating we didn't see her for
the rest of the trip
um so then yeah we make it to the dinner
and we're eating
what happened we have a drink couple
feeling okay i feel a little difficult
good feeling good
say the least it's close to the end of
the night
and sistine and i go okay you know
dinner's over but we need to go the
restroom
because that's what happens that's what
happens when you have a lot of drinks
and what no we go to the
okay you make it sound way worse
you're like you know at the end of the
night you gotta go to the bathroom
i realized it sounded like that okay
sorry yeah maybe i said yeah am i
but go on i'm sorry okay well this is
part of the story
stop we go to the restroom in the least
weird way possible
um and i go to open the bathroom door
and suddenly the door slams
right in my face as i try to open the
door and someone closes it back on my
shoulder
and sophia's face and she actually
stumbles backwards yeah i know because
it was a smack in the face i thought
my nose broke it hurt so bad right in
the middle
i think about this i'm buzzed i have to
go to the bathroom
and i get basically punched by a door
from previous stories of people somewhat
attacking us in miami you know sophia
does not shy away from a good challenge
so she's immediately ready to fight i
all of a sudden go
back up and i she's like bust into the
door
roll out i go hulk smash
i i'm
this door checked me i checked the door
so i turned green
i turned pissed yeah i turned piss so i
slam open the door and i'm about to get
on this check whoever just slammed the
door in my face yup right i'm ready
and ends up being the bathroom attendant
and i look at her like what the
hell i was i'm about to i'm standing up
straight my hands are in fists i'm
kidding
but i'm like look at her like what was
that and she looks at me she goes
someone just peed on the floor and i
have to clean it up
and then i look at her and i can let me
reiterate i said to her
where and she goes oh no right where
you're standing
i was like oh no yeah so
this random girl fully just squatted
while in line for the bathroom yeah
and we immediately felt terrible for the
bathroom attendant we're like oh my god
i'm like i'm sorry and she looked at me
she goes i'm sorry for
almost breaking your nose but i look
trying to go i'm sorry you have to clean
that that sucks
and i didn't blame her i'd be pissed i'd
probably be even more mad if i were her
well thank god he didn't fall because he
would have fell in the urine
that's true that would have been
terrible so that was something that
happened
in miami but another reason why we're so
tweaky right now i'm realizing it we
haven't slept
at all no we have not what is going on
it's mercury in retrograde no cause we
got a lot of [ __ ] to deal with that
people don't know about and
i think i think we're repressing it to
be honest
and it's now boiling over well i have
things
that kept me up last night for example
what happened to you i got bit
by a bug and you're probably like okay
so what yeah it's
florida you could bed by mosquitoes it
woke me up
at four in the morning i bit my finger
right you bit your finger i'm not going
to show you guys because it's really
ugly
it bit my finger at 4 a.m i woke up
god damn that's itchy it itched so
bad you got an accent as it bit you huh
god
damn god damn she developed an accent
listen to my story i looked out at my
finger it is the size
of a small i was gonna say a small golf
ball but that doesn't make sense
i'd like to say it was ping pong i would
i would imagine a grape
on top of your middle finger hmm that's
pretty swollen
yeah it was not good it was not good so
uh i stayed up till
seven in the morning freaking out and
then i found out there was a huge spider
in my belly and if we know sistine she
doesn't like spiders
i also have arachnophobia so
everyone's like what are they not scared
of now they're like we're saying our own
shadow
but i just feel like away you have to
agree with me every time
there's a bad bite in our family that
makes no sense but you know what i mean
no no i always see
rare bugs you're always the one that
gets bit and it have
an insane reaction to it like we'll all
get bit and we'll put some neosporin
we'll put a band-aid refined you
listen to this when i was 10 yeah i got
bit by a rare spider
true my entire arm turned black and i
had to be hospitalized
hospitalized how about two years ago i
swallowed a bee
yeah you guys i swallowed a bee
and it stung my uvula i had to pull it
out with tweezers
the stinger and i couldn't eat for four
days and i was on steroids for time
i i honestly i have nothing to say and
actually the only thing i have to say is
she was with her ex-boyfriend at the
time and he was laughing when she got
stung by the beast that's what you got
from the story
it was like it's a good thing to bring
on the podcast so i think it's a
positive
i was just hoping you could have just
said sorry i've heard
oh oh just because you hear my stories
all the time
you they don't mean anything to you oh
oh
okay and then watch me not care about
sophia for the rest of this podcast
oh my god i'm just really tired i know
it's okay
so something that has been actually
keeping me up on a positive note and i
said this to sistine positivity
you guys i found a new discovery
and that is temptation island yes i was
having
i was having uh what's it called i was
having withdrawals
from love island and i was thinking i
need to watch something better than the
australian version it's not that good
the us version horrible the uk
great so i was like i need a new reality
show island
there's nothing that will replace it
temptation island has
done just that my heart isn't 100 full
but it's
it's 80 there and i'll tell you why i
don't know if you guys have heard this
show
it is probably the most absurd
um torturous way i don't need to put
couples in this situation so basically
there's four couples and they've been in
two plus-year relationships
and they separate okay the guys and the
girls
and they go okay you guys are going to
live in your own mansions
and it's going to be filled with 20
single
boys and girls at the end of each week
you guys have a
bonfire or whatever a fire pit
thing you don't come together but the
girls go to the fire pit the guys go and
then they separate their significant
other
of course yeah one article clothing at a
time no you
watch footage of specific things that
happened
that your significant other did in the
house so for example
i lost my [ __ ] this morning lost it
oh is that why you were screaming i was
screaming because
it is the most absurd show i've ever
seen at first i didn't
like it and i just said you know i'm
just gonna keep going with it i keep
hearing about this show
this one guy has been with this
girlfriend for three years
right and she's been so good about it he
keeps seeing footage of her going to
these guys saying
i really like you but i'm gonna respect
my relationship like he wanted to come
on to the show and so i'm just gonna do
good by him and like be the good
girlfriend
what she saw oh no this boy oh no
she watched footage of her boyfriend of
three plus years
have a threesome with two of the chicks
in the house
she watched it it was on for a good
minute
imagine in my i
i was speech i think it's been a long
time since i physically
swat swatted my hand over my mouth and
gasped
we think we're having a bad day think
about this think about that who would
ever i'm sorry
who would ever oh i just dropped
the drink on you you guys i love when a
day gets worse and sofia spills
a seltzer all over my computer they're
just expressive with my hands
um mike
thank you thank you sophia um
please continue go ahead please stand by
i can't i can't i can't i'm gonna move
this over
you know what i'm sitting in some wet
shorts right now
i'm not putting this i just feel like
let's just add on let's just add on
what's the sound on tuesday
while sistine's cleaning i'll just
finish what i was trying to say
go watch it i'm watching season two it's
the first season i've ever seen
and it is insane and i would never do
this i don't know what couple wants to
ever do this but i commend you guys
for doing it wait so do you think
actually i don't commend you guys for
doing it i don't know why you would do
it
do you think first of all i feel like
the people that sign up for the show
know that their partner's gonna cheat
your relationship has to be in the
[ __ ] yeah to sign it for a show
to test your relationship like this what
is what is the point though do you get
money in the end
i actually don't no i think you i'm
assuming you do there has to be some
benefit to this yeah
right because i feel like going out in
general you're already testing your
relationship when you go to a bar when
you go to a
a club you're testing your boyfriend or
your girlfriend to not do something
shitty and shady
i don't think i could handle that show i
would lose
my mind i would lose it do you know why
because i would probably
get with one of the guys kidding
i would probably watch the door so your
boyfriend wouldn't come in
you'd be blocking the cameras they'll be
like where's the footage
it's just my face in front of the camera
though i smile nothing to see here
cheese cheese cheese
and that's our you i'm so sorry you guys
honestly you guys would probably laugh
at this episode but
we we're just as chaotic right now as
you think this episode is
it's when you don't sleep you just start
seeing
stars and delusion yes i feel like i'm
on laughing gas right now i am feeling
like you know
then this is what we're gonna do next i
was gonna say that we can go into
another topic that we
are going to talk about but i think
while we're on this kind of giggly
rollerco roller coaster thank you why
don't we read
the bedtime story that girl submitted
yes okay
so a few weeks ago we've been doing this
whole bedtime
story segment
[Music]
and we told you guys we would love to
hear your
bedtime stories and this girl submitted
an incredible hilarious story
too good to not share i was so happy
when i got this in our dms and this girl
wrote such a good one with the perfect
amount of description
that we were on the floor laughing so
hard yeah
and i want to commend you i'm not going
to say her name going to keep it
anonymous
but i want to also reiterate if you guys
want
us to read not only your unsolicited
advice but this is not bedtime stories
send us a dm send us through our new
email it's unwaxedpodcast.gmail.com
some crazy stories we'll keep it
anonymous and
we'll read them on air and it'd be
really fun and this girl killed it for
the first one we're gonna share so
thank you for listening thank you for
submitting
here is her story sorry and i told her
we were having it on and she sounded
really excited about it my bedtime story
so my now ex and i had sex on the second
date the weather was miserable so what
else is there to do but watch a movie
she put the little side-eye emoji smile
we had some of the best sex i've ever
had
it was sweaty it was steamy
it was hot just hot yes
yes girl i don't know what came over me
and i've never
done this before and i still freaking
cringe after
six years later i said
high five we're both laying down on
our backs eyes closed panting i was to
his left
i went for a high five and i swung my
left arm
around and up with no energy he
still had the after sex
boner and i didn't realize until it was
too late
that i didn't reach his hand to
high-five him because
i high-fived his parts
his parts so hard he rolled off the bed
moaning in agony
he stood up holding himself against the
window
this was our second date and i didn't
know what to do or how he
would react i said can i get you
anything
or should i leave no answer
then i repeat should i leave
that's my favorite part the second
answer knowing
full well that i just [ __ ] up any
chance i had with this beautiful man
we stayed together for five years and we
both still think it's the funniest thing
ever and i hope you do too
much love round of applause
that's an incredible story this sounds
so similar to just stories that i've had
where i remember one time
after a first date with this guy in
college the end of the night i think i
told you this my freshman year
it was he like walked me to my dorm and
he's like i had a really good night
and when i did because i was nervous was
put my fist out
and i spist pumped him i fist bumped him
and he looked at me looked at my hand
like i just
was holding a bag of poop
or something yeah and was handing it to
him and he
slowly just and walked away
so when i say the high five thing is
very very um
something i would probably do uh you
know what you're a legend
you're a legend for that and obviously
he didn't care that much of you guys
dated for five years after
but you know what it shows you you can
act up and
not act up but like be silly mess up and
it really isn't definitive of what's
going to happen in the relationship
and i love that she owns it and i love
that they both laugh about it because it
is a funny story like that's too short
that's hilarious like those are the
stories you want to have that you want
to look back on and crack up on you know
what start high fiving after sex
all the time 20 21 yes high five
that's what's up what a good story thank
you for submitting again
remember if you want us to read your
bedtime stories make sure you dm us the
story or
submit it to our unwaxed gmail that is
in the instagram bio
sofia i know you wanted to talk about
something well and i didn't exactly know
what so why don't you take it from here
well i had a couple ideas i remember i
facetimed you
going over some topics but i really
liked when we came on and we talked
about something that wasn't always so
goofy
sex whatever all the time and i think
it's important to talk about things we
actually
do know about and it's the benefits of
spending time with yourself
and i know that sounds scary yes hanging
out with yourself
is really freaky and i feel like a lot
of people actually struggle with
it and i know that i've always been good
about it but i didn't realize how much
it was a problem until i got to college
where i had so many girlfriends that
could not
sit by themselves during lunch that
could not just
go walk to class by themselves or eat
dinner by themselves or
go study by themselves that way no well
really
no i feel like i've never felt that way
because i grew up
bullied and we can always get into that
later but
i always kind of isolated myself in
general naturally and i'd go to the
library and i would read
i would go do homework during my off
breaks and so i'd
read and have lunch by myself and so i
never felt
like that was uncomfortable and i kind
of felt to love it and now i always feel
like i need my space
don't you ever feel like that 100 i'm
always trying to be
alone and i think for a long time
i thought that i needed to not be
surrounded by friends but always be in a
relationship to be secure with myself
so i always found validation through
the people that i would date for example
if a guy said you're really pretty then
i would believe i was pretty if if he
said
oh you're actually smart then i would
believe i was smart so
it took me about two years because i
remember i was 19 that was the lowest
i'd ever felt i was in a relationship
that wasn't good for me
and i truly felt alone even though i was
dating someone i was living alone i had
no friends
and learning to be okay with that
took honestly two years and it was
really
really hard and then i went to school
and knew absolutely no one so right
i think it's very healthy because at the
end of the day the only relationship
that
in your life that is ever going to
matter the most is the one that you have
with yourself
so if you don't take care of that or you
don't know
how to be okay with being alone then
i mean how how it's so hard to even
function
day to day well you know what it is is
that we
we can join alone being alone and
learning
loneliness as to the same thing we think
that when we're alone
that we're lonely that we don't have
friends that we don't have people around
us and that
we need others to validate like what you
were saying even if
it's a friend or if it's a boyfriend we
don't believe that our own company is
satisfactory
and so i i was writing this down i was
trying to think of notes
and for me what i've found was like
being alone
is i think a hidden strength i think
it's really really hard
no seriously and it's i'm proud of you
that you're able to get to this point
but
i really encourage people to try to
take yourself on a lunch date take
yourself to a movie by yourself go to a
park
walk your dog like do something alone
and embrace that quality time
that you have with yourself because i'm
telling you the most insane ideas
the most grand realizations is when
i'm alone it's true and you know it's
funny too
a lot of people think oh my god if i go
eat by myself if i go for a walk by
myself
that other people are going to look at
me and say why are you eating
no one cares no one cares no one cares
and i did that all the time i would eat
by myself
i got to a lonely point you guys where i
had every meal by myself that i would
listen to a podcast during dinner
so i could feel like i was having a
conversation with someone well you did
watch um mukbangs with trish the other
week
when you're having dinner that's my
point though yeah it's weird but you
have to own it and no one else cares
everyone else
you know everyone goes through their
thing yeah and you know it's
i think that when you're if you're an
introvert it's really easy to kind of go
into that little isolated place
more so just because you are more
comfortable being by yourself and kind
of having your own space but
if you're an extrovert and what if all
your friends are canceling and your
family's not around and you don't have a
boyfriend what are you gonna do
like are you gonna be overwhelmed about
it feeling like i need to be around
what if your friend isn't there to pick
up the phone yeah yeah like really maybe
even like i say going to a bar that has
a bunch of people i still feel like
that's not being alone like that's
really you're still around
people you can talk to anybody i think
it's a step forward
in the right direction i think maybe a
lot of kids now that the year
is approaching graduation and a lot of
kids are probably going to start feeling
this way where they were
constantly surrounded by their peers and
just people and bodies
all of the time and now you know
life begins workforce is starting yeah
and everyone's moving all around the
country and you know what it is it's
gonna be the same
totally and i feel like when you're
around people all the time you are
in a way jaded or overflooded
with ideas and perceptions and
opinions of everybody else that once you
get to that
ending point of college or whatever
space in your life
where you have to just think freely for
yourself
it's a it's a dead end because you're
like i haven't really had that time to
do that and
i think it's i mean you can start at any
time but i think it's really amazing if
you can just have that introspection
and just think freely for yourself and
know that you don't need
to be around people all the time i think
it's important to have people around and
i know that especially with kovid
we've been really isolated so of course
like there's nothing more that we all
want than to be around people but
i just thought about it because now
we're all coming to this place where
we're starting to come out a little bit
more like we're things are opening up
go re-learn who you are after this
entire
like craziness has been happening yeah
you know
yeah i'm glad you brought that up thank
you i feel like it's one of those things
that
people often look at loneliness as being
weak and
and being insecure but i think it's
quite the opposite i think that if
you're that secure with yourself that
you don't need to rely on others to
find happiness or entertainment or
enjoyment then i think that's
really confident and cool it's
destroying that fear of being alone
and just trusting that you're enough
nice work thank you nice work so i hope
you guys like that um
we can keep doing those if you're
enjoying it and i would just really like
to have an open conversation because
even if
sistine didn't agree with me i would
love for even you to just like
debate me on stuff i'll debate you on
anything
bet bet should make another bet go ahead
make two friends
[Music]
oh god i hope you guys cringed at that
last episode as much as i did
should we go to unsolicited advice i
think we do it all right let's do it
you guys just a reminder of how to
submit your questions for our
unsolicited advice
segment make sure you go to the apple
podcast page go to ratings and reviews
leave your question in the ratings and
review section that is the only way
we're going to answer it i see you guys
are doing it you're doing it correctly
we read
every single comment so thank you guys
so much for even
submitting anything we really do
appreciate it also even if you don't
have a question
just leaving a rating and review is so
so so so important to us and we really
really really do appreciate it if you
can share any support subscribe
subscribe
[Music]
and i don't blame you because when i
used to listen to podcasts i would not
do any of that and now
i do it all the time because i i
understand this world and it really is
beneficial when you subscribe when you
rate when you comment
it helps us help us out you know what i
was thinking
maybe we do a little giveaway with the
listeners yeah
we do a giveaway something like we'll
give away something really cool
and in return you have to screenshot
that you grabbed your phone and
three other people's phones subscribe to
the unboxed podcast i don't know i'm
spitballing here i like that idea okay
so figure it out
if you guys want a surprise gift from us
and we will share what it is next week
you should get three of your friends to
subscribe show a video
and send it to us and one of you guys
will win and
you'll get a really cool prize and you
get to listen to great content
you're welcome you're welcome okay so
this question was submitted by
t-money love that
they said my name is taylor or my
nickname t-money
and i'm currently a sophomore in college
i'm about to turn 20 this month and i
really haven't had the best luck with
relationships
college really felt like a fresh start
for my social and love life
i was in a big city and no longer living
in the middle of nowhere
then the pandemic happened where i had
to move back to the middle of nowhere
and had to operate my sophomore year
online where my social life was nearly
non-existent and ruined my chances with
any girl i was interested in
i plan to return back to campus in the
fall but i'm worried since i haven't
been social
that it'll be hard making new friends or
talking to girls i don't have much
self-confidence
and i tend to overthink a lot which is
what you've talked about before
but do either of you have any advice on
how i can get back into a good social
life thank you so much
okay that was a lot
but i completely relate and understand
everything you're feeling
yeah really i mean i feel like you and a
ton of people are going through this
right now i feel like you and everyone
in the world
has felt this way one time or another i
mean getting back in the social
scene and getting back into that routine
and kind of relearning how to
talk to people how to flirt all this
stuff like we make jokes about how bad
we're flirting we're being serious like
it's hard and it's even going out to
dinner with friends i know for me i
even get sometimes intimidated by it's
it's difficult and i think that i can
relate to you a lot right now
all of my friends are about to graduate
college and they're all living across
the country
i moved my entire life
to florida and i know no one here and
sophia and scarlet are
going back to la and seeing their
friends and they have their
relationships from school
but i don't so it's really difficult for
me
to put myself out there and reintroduce
myself and
and go out on dates and put myself out
there and the love life and the
friendship life it's really really hard
but it's one of those things that if you
don't push yourself
to get back up on that horse no one's
going to do it for you
i was going to say a good way to just
integrate yourself a little bit more is
go to those friends you know you feel
the most comfortable with
and start just there go out with them go
get a drink with them or
i don't know how old you are go get
dinner with them and
get into that rhythm and then the next
day reach out to another person i think
what you have to do which we don't do
all the time
is put in the effort to reach out first
100
000 i always
am the one that is too shy oh maybe if i
text this person i haven't talked to
them in so long
why would they answer me you guys they
always answer and then they're excited
excited about it i think be that person
that starts the train because
you know as susan just said they are
really happy to be going to that dinner
with you they want to hang out with you
everyone is in that same boat taylor
like everyone is feeling the same way
so the best way to go about it even for
anybody that's not in school just in
general
put in the steps send that text do not
overthink it
it's really dumb to overthink attacks
because it's not worth it in terms of
confidence and
confidence with the ladies they don't
know
you're not confident only you do okay so
as long as you fake it till you make it
they don't have to know what you're
feeling inside and by the way
they're just as nervous too oh my god no
one is
no one has to get there no no one is
secure in their skin so
i'm insecure i'm not confident most of
the time
but i sort of present myself and hold
myself away that people
think i'm the most confident person in
the world so that's just what you have
to do
exactly and then once you get the train
rolling it will be
so easy and you will know exactly what
to do and it will feel like this never
happened in the first place
yeah you know kova took a lot away from
a lot of people
and a lot of people are feeling the
exact same way as you
i was talking about this with my mom
this morning i feel extremely stagnant
in my life
i feel like nothing is gonna change i
feel like the way things were will never
be what it was
but that's not true no everyone's on the
same boat as you
we're all gonna get back to normalcy
one step at a time and i have a good
feeling about this year i think things
are gonna pick up and i think that you
should
get a head start on it before the
floodgates open and
all the restaurants really open up and
all the bars and by the way
be really excited to have that new
social life or get back together
keep us updated with the ladies if you
need some one-liners sophie and i got
you
gotcha and we will help you out speaking
of unwaxed
uh unsolicited advice comments and
questions before we end our show i
i don't think cysteine uh knows i'm
gonna ask her but
speaking of unsolicited advice last week
um
we brought in two questions we had
scarlet answer about her ex-boyfriend
but before that
sistine answered a question about remy
the ratatouille
right remember the rummy the rat not
from the remy the ratatouille remy the
rat from wrath
disrespect my king but do you remember
the title of
the question it was girl in red yeah um
it was something about like
the sistine does sistine listen read
read girl
girl in red yeah and i think you thought
it was something
i don't know what you thought it was
erotica you thought it was erotica
i got a dm from someone and
maybe we're the only two people on this
planet that didn't know of this
but it basically is asking if you swing
to the girls side
what yeah it was just asking if you um
like if you're
are interested in girls i didn't realize
that's what the term meant that's what
girl in writing yeah it's not a
it's not an erotica my dumb ass was
looking it up on my kindle
bookstore you were looking for that
i want to thank the person that reached
out to me and said that because i just
realized i remembered i watched it back
and i remember it's the scene going i
guess that's erotica
i don't know i'm so dumb it's okay
wow oh my god it's i spent like an hour
on that
yeah i know you're really looking for it
that's why i'm happy that this girl
reached out so i just thought it was
funny to bring up because we didn't know
what it meant and thank you for guys for
letting us know that's how much i know
gee
that's how much i know we are so lame
we're in like we should get back with
the you know what it is we probably need
to do our research
on that like we should have looked up
what that meant before
is it like a hidden terminology i don't
know is it
like code the girl in red is an openly
lesbian artist
who writes a lot of girl on girl songs
if a girl asks another girl if they
listen to the girl in red they're
basically asking hey do you like girls
by any chance
i had no idea that's really kind of cool
that's kind of an interesting way to ask
that's really cool so if you guys are
curious on how to ask girl that you
should just ask that
that's a cool way that was really sly
that was slick
all right you learn something new every
day okay well you know what
i think we end on that note thank you
guys uh for listening to our once again
super chaotic um sleep deprived
episode today thank you guys for hanging
in there i know that it was going
up and down sideways drinks were spilt
but we love doing this you guys we love
it and we love you talking right to you
even though we're acting a little loopy
we're so happy to be here so thank you
guys for listening
we will see you next tuesday bye
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at unwax
podcast your producer is will sterling
we'll see you next week